my co-host on the air today ramsey
personality Ken Coleman host of the Ken
Coleman show where we talk about he
talks about careers and jobs every day
and we're now up to 36 million
unemployed so you got something to do my
brother's telling you what it is
really really important that people have
an idea how to get clear because it's
gonna be one of the most competitive job
markets in our history because those
numbers are probably gonna balloon past
40 million Dave as we see some may
numbers will come out and and yet at the
same time while those unemployment
numbers are big we're seeing the economy
is thawing out state after state opening
up even the governor of California who
just a week ago was saying we should go
for three more months maybe this pro
sports can begin activities in June so I
think you're now seeing a shift the
collective of United States mentality is
alright let's open up and so hopefully
that means jobs are gonna come back in
the service sector in the retail sector
so people better get ready Dave because
I think you're gonna see those
employment numbers begin to shift we
don't know how quickly nobody does but I
think better days are ahead there's
definitely a check mark effect I mean
yeah as as businesses open up this real
simple they need employees the problem
is that for a free market guy like
myself I'm seeing the unintended
consequence of the federal government
Democrats and Republicans signing the
largest stimulus bill in history and so
guess what the unemployed have no know
once they have to go back to work that's
exactly where the furloughed have no
incentive to go back to work I was I
mentioned this before I was with a
friend of mine this weekend that owns a
restaurant he's having trouble staffing
he's reopened but the people that used
to work for him now make more sitting on
their butts with unemployment plus six
hundred dollars a week from the
government until that runs out he's
gonna have trouble getting back and
guess what that's gonna make it look
like the unemployment is worse than it
is that's right because there's jobs
available and so many people don't want
to go back to work well you're looking
at July 25th folks that is going to run
out and so you're really hedging your
bets here that you
told your employer you know what I make
more money staying at home than I do
working and they may replace you and I
wouldn't be surprised if they don't and
what's interesting I saw some data
yesterday I wish they would I would too
because I don't like it I don't like it
at all when you're offered work there is
and I get I get the math but this isn't
math this is about dignity dignity the
human spirit all of us long to work I'm
not on welfare if I don't know
that's exactly right those funds should
be going to other people that might be
in a much different situation are not
running up the federal debt either one
well I'm with you there I don't think
you know listen yeah this is from Forbes
an unintended unexpected consequence of
the multi trillion dollar stimulus
package is that workers are asking to be
laid off yeah
or reluctant asking to be laid off right
well look at the minimum wage 15,000 to
go back to work after being furloughed
in an effort to help people financially
cope with the job losses the midst of
the pandemic the federal government
which can screw up Christmas is
providing an extra $600 a week in
unemployment benefits and this amounts
to an you know this amount is in
addition to these states what the states
already pay which is in the range of two
to three hundred a week so a person
could conceivably earn a thousand
dollars a week on unemployment fifty two
thousand dollars a year yeah depending
if they went for a whole year
that's those annualized depending on the
state he or she resides in situation
facing companies that have already been
financially hurt by consequences of Cova
19 outbreak consider a worker at an
Amazon warehouse the worker has to be on
their feet all day lift heavy boxes on
and off shelves race around the facility
fulfill orders like work earning a
minimum wage of $15 per hour by the way
that's not the minimum wage that's their
minimum wage the person may make pre-tax
525 a week think of how many millions of
other people work at dangerous
physically demanding or unpleasant jobs
earning a similar amount not to
disparage anyone but it's enticing for a
person to be asked to be laid off so
they can earn more money than they were
making at work let's look at the flip
side tama-reien cited in the same
article out of michigan small
businessman because of these government
unemployment payments he is now paying
906
dollars per week that's $80 higher than
what he pays his welders and $353 more
than some of his average workers so this
government's screwing up Christmas
they're hurting the small businessman a
woman who we talk about all the time
here who's trying to recover from him
they are the recovery they are the
backbone so you know these unemployment
benefits sound really great until you
realize Tom Moran is a guy who's
creating jobs and we're a very small the
government does creates nothing yeah so
it's a real problem and we need to get
back to what was it was done with the
right intention but sure time you any
time you just go bananas which they did
they just went bananas with this there
should have been some checks and
balances on but oh yeah we're gonna buy
your votes that's here comes Pelosi and
Trump one thing they can agree on run
the nation another two trillion dollars
into debt and let's put let's put just
almost nothing on this just turn it
loose and shut the place down
unbelievable I mean yeah and so the that
blame mm-hmm if you can't find a job
right now it's a you ain't looking yeah
they're everywhere yeah everybody's
hiring and everybody's opening up and
they're desperate for you to come back
to work yeah so it's here's an
interesting interesting time we don't
have this problem at remedy solutions
because we don't have anyone
number one we didn't lean by off number
two we don't we're not hiring any
positions that are below that well there
probably are below fifty two thousand
dollars a year I do have some below that
I don't know if we're hiring them today
but you know hypothetically someone
would say I don't want to start the new
job at Ramsay until this runs out in
which case I would not hire them right
well again this is this benefit is not
infinity and beyond folks we're talking
about your lie twenty-fifth I know but
that's general much yeah but the point
is is why why mortgage your future on
the immediate I just don't like it it's
not because everybody thinks short-term
well you know none for the next row but
for the next four weeks I can cash out
understand them so I don't want us I
don't want to go take the job that I got
sitting in front of me I mean that
hypothetically could happen here cuz
we've opened our hiring back up right
we've started hiring again
gradually were very gradually very
slowly very carefully wisely mm-hmm
not knee-jerk reaction and over do
something right right well here's how
that's gonna backfire Dave let's just
run some numbers the current numbers are
thirty-six point five million people
unemployed now watch this folks let's
just round that down to 30 million for
just some simple math in the coming
weeks and months let's say that 30
million people on average each person
submits five resumes I think that's
really really low based on the data
that's a hundred and fifty million
resumes flooding the marketplace let's
put it up to ten you're doing the math
with me that's 300 million resumes I
think it's closer to twenty and more 600
million resumes so if you're playing
this July 25th I'm going to sting is
Linkedin gonna break
I don't know got a venue right now you
could really hurt yourself if you've got
an opportunity to go back to work and
take go back to work as man Wow that's
true that's my point
other people are gonna get your job and
then when this runs out they're not
gonna be oh that's a good point I think
that's where it backfires
yeah back to work